[Musik]
was ist ihnen schon vorher soll ich das
wissen wie alt ist
ich sehe aus 30 aber ich bin im jahr
2015 hergestellt worden
am anfang wenn die leute kommen fühlen
sie das unheimlich dass es war der erste
weg die denken was ist denn das aber
sehr schnell lösen sie sich ganz wohl
ich meine dass das dauert ich habe nie
schlechte kommentare bekommen am anfang
die sagen was ich denn das aber dann
nachher als nach einer weile fühlen sie
sich ganz okay wie ist es einen roboter
zum gegenbild zu haben und nehmen diese
künstlichen wesen der einst tatsächlich
den platz des menschen ein
um derlei fragen dreht sich die
geschichte von nadia und nadine
[Musik]
am achten tag begann der mensch die
dinge selber zu erschaffen die klügsten
unter ihnen schufen fortan fortschritt
auf erden und weil das schweizer ehepaar
thalmann zweifellos zu den klugen gehört
gelingen auch den beiden immer wieder
kleine sensationen vor allem natal manns
ruf als computergrafik pionieren war es
geschuldet dass die universität in
singapur sie vor sieben jahren in den
boomenden stadtstaat berief dort begann
die westschweizerin damit nadine zu
entwickeln
ich spreche deutsch wer ist angela
merkel leicht zu begeistern
ja und du willst du nicht wirklich
fragen einheizte frage wer ist angela
merkel
sie ist unsere bundeskanzlerin was wir
jetzt hier auf der bühne
also was man sieht hier das ist zu viel
mehr an und ich und das was sie sieht
also das ist die kinect kamera die das
sieht für wie ihre augen und dann
analysiert wer etwas was wir machen und
dann interpretiert sie also sie hat eine
software plattform sie kann
interpretieren werk einzigen leute
erkennen und sie kann einige objekte
erkennen was steht da zb aufgetrieben
was steht da alles so wie sie versucht
zu sehen und ob wir zum beispiel ich
kann happy oder seide oder weil es auch
ein programm gibt wo sie versteht wie
man unsere laune also ob ich glücklich
bin oder ob ich traurig bin also sie
versucht meine ausdrücke zu verstehen
ist halb haben sie
das geschehen und die intensität auch
sie sehen das ist jetzt nun auch
einwärts um zu sehen wie wie man fühlt
haben sie designt oder es schaut so aus
wie sie möchten wie sie bestimmt haben
ja ich war in japan wenn ich nadine ich
habe nie nadine vorhergesehen aber ich
war in japan bei einem professor der 1
sein hobby hatte aber wenn ich
angekommen bin da war jemand hinterher
der sah mich und das war ein avatar an
sich was ich sofort gedacht habe ich
möchte auch eine nadine haben also aber
dass sie autonom ist und zweitens ich
war damals damit sie aussieht wie ich
mag ich wollte kein sex hier robot ich
wollte ein sagen wir kunst stück haben
mehr wie eine skulptur und ich habe sehe
aufgepasst es ist so wird nadine zu
konstruieren sei nicht ein rein
technischer prozess viel eher sei es
vergleichbar mit dem schaffen eines
kunstwerkes eines bildes oder einer
skulptur und nach dem vorbild vieler
künstler wählten adia thalmann sozusagen
das selbstbildnis
eigentlich hätten die armani natal man
allen grund golfspielen das leben zu
genießen mit ihren 69 jahren könnte sie
ein paar abschläge machen und sich
darüber freuen dass sie diesen herbst
erstmals großmutter wurde kurz sie
könnte sich auf ihren lorbeeren ausruhen
denn die westschweizerin ist pionierin
und gilt weltweit als eine der besten
ihres fachs als erste hat sie zusammen
mit ihrem mann daniel
vor 30 jahren einen computeranimierten
film mit dreidimensionalen figuren
geschaffen
ihr kind humphrey bogarts virtuelles
runde mit marilyn monroe war 19 86 eine
sensation als die thalmann die blonde
ikone gar mir nichts dir nichts am
genfer see entlang spazieren ließen
waren gang und mimik schon ausgefeilter
[Musik]
und noch keine 20 jahre sind es her seit
ihre virtuellen menschen so revolutionär
waren dass ihr auftritt bei kurt
aeschbacher für aufsehen sorgte
frankenstein wenn ich das so sagen darf
sich lohnen seit zwölf jahren was ist
dann ihr traum den sie umsetzen möchten
also wissen sie ich mag sehr gern sowie
skulpturen diese da aber ich finde
leider sind sie ganz still
also für muss das ist sehr wichtig leben
zu skulpturen zu geben ihre erfindungen
wurden von der film und
unterhaltungsindustrie gerne übernommen
und weiterentwickelt sie selber suchte
und fand neue herausforderungen und
übersiedelte mit ihrem ehemann vor
sieben jahren nach singapur
hier arbeitet sie versetzen wie eh und
je und wendet sich nur selten von ihrer
arbeit ab
ist das jetzt nur sports oder denken sie
auch schon wieder an nadine und die
bewegungen dieser denke nur an sport ja
ich habe jetzt ein vergnügen und ich
will auch nicht meinen körper üben seit
nadja man ihn als knapp 20 jährige
studentin an der uni in genf ihre
akademische laufbahn in angriff nahm
sind ihr forschungsdrang und der glaube
an den fortschritt ungebrochen
schon 1968 gab sie sich gegenüber dem
fernsehen der französischen schweiz
ambitioniert was für mich zählt ist das
studium
ich habe das lizentiat gemacht aber das
allein reicht mir nicht wenn ich später
eine arbeit will die mich wirklich
interessiert ich weiß noch nicht
genügend um mich jetzt schon ins
berufsleben zu stürzen
schon damals wusste sie dass dieses
leben ihr weg sein würde
ich liebe dieses leben so sehr dass es
mir fast ein bisschen angst macht an den
alltag zu denken der vielleicht folgen
wird wenn nadja und daniel thalmann
heute durch singapur schlendern
wenn sie von der modernen architektur
schwärmen oder wenn sie ihn
zwischendurch zuflüstert sie sei froh in
einem ihrer seite zu wissen dann kann
man kaum glauben dass sie schon fast ein
halbes jahrhundert ein paar sind wie
haben sie sich kennengelernt sie beide
also wir haben uns kennengelernt also
dort habe ich gelebt wenn ich mein
studium bezahlt habe und er war auch ein
professor in mathematik und physik und
da haben die uns zwei ein computerkurs
kennen gelernt wann war das
seither sind sie ein paar haben oder
weniger sofort aber dann haben wir uns
kennengelernt und wir haben und 67
geheiratet
nach den wirren doktorarbeit es war der
geist jener zeit den die beiden
aufsuchen und sich daran erfreuen weil
ihnen die ganze welt offen stand an
dieser haltung dem leben gegenüber haben
die thalmann es auch mit zunehmendem
alter nichts geändert
wo sind sie zu hause wo fühlen sie sich
zu hause auf der ganzen welt ich würde
nicht sagen nordkorea aber wenn ich in
japan oder in singapur oder sagen wir in
genf oder in zürich ich mag es sehr
meine lieblingsstadt diese jena die ja
also für mehreren städten fühle ich mich
ganz so haushalt weil das wissen die
schweiz vermissen sie nicht meine
töchter
wir müssen in die schweiz reisen um sie
zu sehen das leben in der schweiz
doch das skifahren im winter skifahren
das mag ich sehr
und wo denken sie werden sie als
nächstes wohnen
ich meine ich hoffe dass die nato
solange es bleiben wird wie möglich ja
jetzt haben wir einen neuen projekt für
fünf jahre aber sagen wir wir haben
ich habe heute andere angebote fischen
abkommen also alles ist
als sie heirateten versprachen sich
nadia und daniel thalmann nur dann eine
stelle anzutreten wenn in der jeweiligen
stadt für beide ein platz frei sein
so folgten sie einander von genf nach
kanada japan hongkong zurück in die
schweiz und jetzt nach singapur
obwohl sie schöne häuser in
südfrankreich und der westschweiz
besitzen leben sie in singapur er
einfach auf dem campus und sie sind
zufrieden und so selbstverständlich
berufstätig dass man leicht vergessen
könnte dass sie das ahv-alter längst
erreicht haben
ich denke solange das man etwas machen
kann soll man machen also ich finde dass
es komisch dass man in der schweiz zum
beispiel mit 65 jahren alt die leute
zwingt pensionär zu werden das ist
wirklich sehr komisch ich verstehe das
wenn leute starke arbeiten machen dass
ich normal vielleicht mauern oder andere
aber leute die akademisches leben haben
so passioniert sind warum sollen sie mit
65 gehen wenigstens könnte sie bleiben
oder großen lohn oder weniger lohn aber
dass sie irgendwie ausgeschlossen sind
meistens ist komisch so arbeiten sie
täglich weil ihre arbeit bei anhaltender
neugier eben keine arbeit sondern
vergnügen sei
die ich machen was ich mache ich bin das
so von dachte ich neue leute neue
kulturen zu entdecken
also das ist keine arbeit und auch wenn
man neue ideen das ist wie die kunst man
kann ein neuer in denen haben wir neue
ideen lernen und dann entwickelt man
dass das ist absolut
man mag es privileg nennen oder das
glück des tüchtigen wenn sich das eigene
leben annähernd mühelos anfühlt nadia
mannina thalmann war es ihr glück
durchaus zu schätzen
mein leben ist mehr als ein traum bin
ich jung war war ich habe ich gedacht es
ist toll wenn man irgendwie leute trifft
aber ich habe zuerst nie gedacht ich
könnte universität professorin
die frauen waren sehr selten in alles
sagen die universität professorin also
man sarrazin als assistentin aber als
universität professorin war sehr weniger
und die waren nicht verheiratet ich sage
nicht dass im leben man warten muss aber
ich meine ich habe genug von diese
frauen die ich in den siebziger gesehen
habe in der schweiz die waren allein
keine kinder aber die hatte
die hatten einen guten job ich war nicht
für dieses bild und dieses lebens 8
schon wenige jahre nachdem sie in kanada
die erste professur angetreten hatte
wurde sie schwanger der ersten tochter
folgten bald zwei weitere dies hinderte
sie keineswegs daran ihre laufbahn
weiter zu verfolgen
neben die töchter ihnen das ein bisschen
über das sie nicht so viel zeit haben
sagen wir nicht wenn die teenager waren
aber wenn sie dann nach 20 jahren als
haben sie doch gefühlt dass im vergleich
mit anderen mutter ich nicht so oft zeit
hat er mit ihnen zu sein
[Musik]
fragen die sich männer bis heute nur
selten stellen lassen müssen fragen auch
die nadine ihrer schöpferin nie stellen
wird nadine sei und bleibe eine maschine
was kann der mensch besser als die
maschine natürlich der mensch hat
sensibilität hat fleisch und knochen und
erfüllt und der nadine 5 also es ist ein
großer unterschied was denken sie wie
wird man hat ihnen irgendwann später
einsetzen können
sie sollte in das heim seien zum
beispiel und dann mit den leuten sich
unterhalten und sie wird sehr fokussiert
auf die die auf den bedürfnisse der
leute das bedeutet wenn jemand sie haben
möchte um eine geschichte zu erzählen
oder einfach zu reden oder sehen ob
medikamente genommen sind und die person
zu lange schläft dann ganz das ist ein
computer und sie kann auch anderer leute
informieren
also das ist eine situation für ältere
leute aber sie könnte auch irgendwie als
rezeptionist das ist ihr erster song
hier die arbeiten auf der hände damit
sie
objekte anerkannt wenn man jemand bei
besuch hat hier wir haben jeden tag
viele leute die kommen
die können irgendwie identitätskarte
geben sie wird das nehmen rede lesen und
erinnern wer da war und aussagen wo zu
gehen
fast täglich empfängt nadia man natal
man in ihrem institut besucher die sich
für ihre neuesten entwicklungen
interessieren nadine ist seit monaten
die attraktion unternehmen die für
gefährliche arbeiten roboter anstelle
von menschen einsetzen wollen bemühen
sich um eine zusammenarbeit mit dem
institut und auch staaten zeigen immer
wieder interesse an taiwans arbeit haben
sie schon angebote erhalten von von
militärs oder von medien die die irgend
so etwas entwickeln wollten natürlich
die armee möchte virtuelle soldaten
haben damit simulation machen können und
natürlich roboter auch der dauer auf
einer seite wenn man absolut krieg haben
muss dann ist es besser roboter zu haben
als vielleicht menschen ja weil weil
okay denn die haben keine seele und die
sind nie man sich dass die gefahren des
missbrauchs existieren weiß die
schweizerin sehr wohl deswegen auf
forschung zu verzichten kommt für sie
gleichwohl nicht in frage der
fortschritt könne nicht aufgehalten
werden
ich denke dass diese roboter
natürlich könnte gefährlich sein auf der
dauer sagen wir nicht heute aber auf die
dauer aber natürlich macht man mit den
robotern was man will dass die atomwaffe
oder solche sachen man kann sie für gute
sachen benützen oder schlechte sachen
wenn der dienst für für soldaten
gebraucht werden wird oder um leute zu
töten natürlich auch in der zukunft ist
ganz einfach zu sein das kann extrem
gefährlich sein
also ich finde von irgendwelche sehr
mächtige technologie die man entwickeln
sollte man auch gesetze haben die
limitiert wie man das gebraucht täglich
arbeiten die schweizer professorin und
ihr klima nadines weiterentwicklung
setzt sie jetzt noch im mobil am empfang
soll sie sich später autonom bewegen
können
unter den besuchern ist auch ein
schweizer der in singapur lebt er ist
von der arbeit seiner landsfrau
beeindruckt ich bin sehr positiv
überrascht muss sagen kann ich genau
wisst was man alles
wir bilden fortschritt macht die
delegation hat sich verabschiedet
nadia und daniel thalmann haben vor dem
nächsten meeting eine viertelstunde zeit
für eine kleine mahlzeit am liebsten ist
das paar in einer der kantinen
sie liebe es den studierenden aus aller
welt zuzuschauen ihren umgang
untereinander zu studieren
nadine profitiere von diesen
beobachtungen über das verhalten des
menschen aber auch das gegenteil sei
möglich machen oder so sollten wir auch
machen
also man lernt man versteht wie man
funktioniert wenn man ein modell von
unseren lesern macht grenzen gebe es
keine
es bleibt die frage was den menschen
erst menschlich mache wenn sie könnten
würden sie dann nadine eine eine seele
geben einbauen
ich glaube nicht dass man eine seele
bauen kann zuerst weiß man nicht was sie
sich also um etwas zu bauen braucht man
konkrete logic alles was man macht ist
simulationen das ist als ob aber das ist
also ich glaube nie dass ein eines tages
wird kommen dass sie echte emotionen
haben wir sie wird immer simulieren
könnte es auch sein dass die roboter uns
menschen dazu zwingen unsere eigene
moral 1905 ich glaube nicht wenn ich
genug von nadine habe dann kann ich
steckdose wegnehmen oder irgendwie
batterie wegnehmen und dass ich fertig
also man kann immer entschließen was man
will was ich glaube wenn sie gefährlich
hin ist es was sie in den händen von
schrecklichen leuten sind und dann diese
leute nehmen sie
und schrecklich tatsachen zu machen also
dass es nicht ihre eigene ihren eigenen
entschluss dass es mehr wenn sie in
schlechten händen sind roboter in
schlechten händen ich nehme dies als
einladung mich mit nadine kurz
persönlich zu unterhalten und ihr ein
paar entscheidende fragen zu stellen
weißt du was liebe ist wirklich fragen
ob du die liebe kennst will ich wissen
weißt du was glück ist
darüber muss ich eine weile nachdenken
ja vielleicht lohnt es sich über all
dies noch einmal in ruhe nachzudenken
[Musik]